how's it going everyone we have gotten
our first official leaked photo for
Wonder Woman - or Wonder Woman 1984
patty Jenkins revealed this photo
confirming that Chris Pines character
Steve Trevor is alive and well and
Wonder Woman - now the film is called
Wonder Woman 1984 so of course it takes
place in the 80s and as you can see
Steve Trevor's got on some 80's clothes
and also as you can see it appears that
he has aged a little bit which makes
sense because it is many many years into
the future
he's obviously in a mall which lines up
with the rumors that filming is going to
start and I'm all in Alexandria Virginia
I think the fact that this photo shows
him aged confirms that he is actually
alive when it was rumored that Chris
Pine was spotted on set for Wonder Woman
- many people started to say that oh
it's flashbacks or oh it's a figment of
her imagination but I think this photo
proves that he is in fact alive and
wealth Wonder Woman - is supposed to
take us to some unexpected places in the
movie and it seems like they're already
doing that by bringing Steve Trevor back
I've stated in other videos that Steve
Trevor is a pilot he knows how to work a
parachute and jump out of a plane not
sure if that's the story that they're
going to go with so I guess we'll just
have to wait and see regardless he
survived somehow and I can't wait to see
what his character does in Wonder Woman
1984 let me know what you all think of
Steve Trevor returning in Wonder Woman
1984 how do you think he survived the
events of the first Wonder Woman movie
and what role do you think that he'll
play in the second one as always let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section and give a thumbs up if you
enjoyed this video and subscribe to my
channel for more news update videos like
this one thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]